and I welcome our next speaker Misha is
Dylan profits professor of experimental
physics at giessen University and
co-founder of the desert tech foundation
which studies the use of solar and wind
energy and a fellow german so when we
are talking about a source of energy
which potentially could give us a lot a
thousand years and worth of energy but
energy forever now that's the theory
what about the practice yeah so I'm
talking about having solar energy from
Africa to like this in a way is a crazy
idea and the reason why we need that is
because we have a concern of a problem
which I would like to mention here you
all know that we haven't you all know
that we have an energy problem in the
world this is to reason one is because a
population is rising fast and the second
is because everybody wants to have more
energy than before and if you look at
the scale of the problem you can learn
something it's a moment you have an
energy consumption of about 16,000
gigawatts every moment and in future
this will increase to about 24,000
gigawatts I use the unit gigawatt here
because it's easy to remember that one
nuclear power plant is one gigawatt so
that means that at the moment if you
would run for nuclear hundred percent we
would need sixteen thousand nuclear
power plants and if you know the scale
of this energy problem then you might be
a little bit reluctant if you really
want to have so many nuclear power
plants we want to reduce co2 and that
means that in the next 40 years we have
to install 15,000 gigawatt of new
capacities if you go nuclear you have to
bathe everyday a nuclear power plant for
40 years
if your goal is goal of isola you have
to do the same amount but in the
different technology so the size of the
problem we have is really so
extraordinary that you need new
solutions therefore in a way you can say
desert tech wants to use natural and
nuclear fusion our fusion reactor exists
already our son we are at the safety
distance of hundred fifty billion
kilometres the Sun is highly radioactive
you shouldn't come close to it and the
only thing we still have to build our
solar dishes which catch the energy and
make use of it so what we need to solve
the energy problem isn't technology
which is simple and safe and renewable
so that it will last forever why do we
in desert tech want to use the desert
the reason is simple because in the
desert says most of the solar energy if
you just use current technology you have
about 20 times the solar energy in the
deserts of the world which you need for
the whole energy supply of the whole
mankind so this shows you that the
potential of solar energy in the desert
is immense the technology is simple this
year is a picture taken last year in
Egypt it's a solar tough concentrating
power generator so the only thing you
need is a parabolic mirror and this
taffy in the center you have a pipe
where you eat up some liquid and this
hot liquid goes to a standard power
generator it's same technology as in
nuclear power plants except that our
nuclear reactions is on the Sun and the
steam is generated here in this solar
panels this shows you as a full picture
of this device in Egypt so it works it
can be done anywhere with simple
technology and that is a technology
where we believe we have to do it in
huge numbers to solve energy
one problem of the Sun is that it
doesn't shine at night there is no way
to change that and we still want to have
power at night this is a picture from
Spain you know people in Spain start to
live and the Sun went down I don't know
how it is in London here but probably
similar so you need electricity at night
and the simple way to do it using this
concentrated solar power stations is you
stole the heat you don't store the
electricity and you don't store the
sunlight the heat can be stored in a
very simple way here it's done in these
big tanks you have one tank with a cold
liquid which you heat up over the day
you store it in the second hot tank at
four not degree Celsius about and then
at night you needs it you use this hot
liquid in this case yet sleep with salt
to produce steam which you then used to
produce electricity how do you bring the
electricity from the deserts to the
people where this is simple nowadays
when I started this discussion some 20
years ago the people were thinking of
producing hydrogen and shipping the
hydrogen to Europe nowadays it's very
simple you just need a cable you need
high voltage and you need DC current
normally our electricity network is AC
alternating current this AC current has
a lot of losses the reason one reason is
because you produce electro smoke you
broadcast electromagnetic waves which
and where you lose energy if you used
easy you don't need that you don't have
that anymore the power losses are less
than ten percent over 3,000 kilometers
here's another picture from Spain and
it's another type of solar power plant
it's a solar tower in the center with a
lot of thousands of small metals around
each of the mirrors is remote controlled
and follows the movement of the Sun and
the Sun is focused at the center of this
tower and the sand and they
very high temperatures and high energy
and again you use that to produce
electricity this is one option we have
the hope that in future you don't only
produce electricity this way but also
you can produce liquid fuels this is a
technology which is already working in
the lab one processes you put height you
put water and co2 in and sunlight heat
then you have a catalytic reaction and
from that you could use alcohol and
oxygen so this works in principle but
not on an industrial scale yet there's
another aspect of desert egg which we
have to talk about and that are the
geopolitical aspects of desert egg here
in Europe we have a special situation
because our next desert is in Africa and
the people in effect I have a very
different standard of living compared to
us and we know that there's a strong
eyes of population the amount of water
is going down it will be going down
faster and future because of the climate
change and there will be more people
living in poverty and without food and
water and this will of course produce
not only problems in Africa but also in
Europe and therefore we believe that for
Europe of course it's important to have
renewable energy but it's even more
important to have a secure neighborhood
so desert egg aims to connect the
continents Africa and Europe we bring to
Africa energy and industrialization it
can produce hundred thousands of jobs
with this program and this gives new
perspectives to the young generation
there and that helps to stabilize our
society on the long term here the plot
which shows how its realized or how one
way of granulation is you have the solar
power stations in North Africa you have
the centers of consumption signore
and the only thing you have to do is you
have to have DC cables between Africa
and Europe yeah if you have a new house
and you have in different rooms you need
electricity also put cables to every
room that is the same in a larger scale
here and this value produces the
so-called super grid which has very low
losses this has the advantage you can
get the power from Africa but in
addition it has another advantage
because here in Scotland you want to
have offshore wind farms and we have it
in Germany and in Denmark and in Morocco
as well and Linda's fluctuating but if
you have a super grid you can put the
electricity always there where you need
it so you can average out these
fluctuations to big extend if you look
at costs I'm finishing soon if you look
at the post it's about eight cents a
kilowatt hour which you have to play as
a moment for the solar energy one
example here a British company called to
noir this Tunisian investors has a
project to have a cable from Tunisia to
home by the way today the Ambassador the
British ambassador was in the prime
minister of Tunisia because of this
project and it's not only Britain
there's a big list of companies the
simple desert industrial initiative by
the way she'll is one of the associate
members as well all these big companies
want to earn money use it as a tech
concept so we have we as the desert egg
foundation have some hope that things
are moving in future so to conclude
these are text source for heat problems
it produces when you will and save
energy it produces water by desalination
for Africa it produces hundred thousands
of new jobs as well in Europe as in
Africa and it has peacekeeping and
entons because it stabilizes the
affected region thank you well from one
German to another it's true that you
know anything at a time when our
reputation Europe is that we're throwing
our weight around a little bit again
that smacks potentially of 21st century
colonialism will obviously raise some
eyebrows I would imagine but sort of in
terms of the moral question behind it or
even even a sort of self-interested
question for Europe are we really wise
to yet again make ourselves dependent on
a region that is to say the least
politically unpredictable well as I try
to to say I see the other way round we
think that it stabilizes politically and
we are anyway depending about eighty
percent of our primary energy comes from
foreign countries like the Gaza from
Russia who knows to whom Russia will
sell the gas in 20 years from now there
are other people who like to have gas so
we are anyway depending on different
countries and by having the solar power
from Africa we have a diversification of
this sources in a way right questions
again at the bank the gentleman over
there sorry microphone is coming
hi there this is connected to what you
just said which is essentially that
doesn't this just transfer the power
currently held by Gauss identify
yourself just like Charles Oliver Tom
University and doesn't this is transfer
the power currently held by Gazprom over
the eastern bloc to Italy in Spain they
now have the transport rights to the
power surely they would use that I'm not
saying that's necessarily a bad thing
but isn't that quite a dangerous thing
to hand all of your power connectivity
to other powers question the question
was if it's dangerous to be depending on
these countries or in terms of politics
as well as in terms of transport links
if you will consider if you're
transporting something in line 1000
volts over 6,000 kilometers yes there's
going to be a disruption at some point
well first of all it's not one cable
it's like 20 cables for example secondly
this technology is is used in China for
example a lot nowadays these high
voltage DC lines so it's it's not
different than any other technology we
also have pipelines from Russia to
Europe which are also dangerous
dangerous I guess that is partly the
point isn't it that they are dangerous
and so the question is can we make it
safer but maybe there is nothing but
what what should be the danger of a
high-voltage cable we have it everywhere
here so it's one more cable i don't i
don't think the tech is politically if
anyone would be manipulating it off as i
said there are there are lots of tables
and we always of course have to have
backup capacity so if you have a coal
power plant here in England you
shouldn't use it but you can in case of
a political crisis or if there's some
terroristic attack on the cable you can
switch on your coal power plant again
for a month and prepare the cable and
then you continue with solar energy at
two questions will have the gentleman
here and the lady over there keep it
really short please Martin Livermore
from the scientific alliance I I should
say that I think the idea of getting
energy for the Sun
ultimately is an excellent one because
that's where all the energy does come
from but I think that what we're talking
about here currently is is probably the
most expensive form of renewable energy
certainly photovoltaics are and I have
no reason to suppose that thermal solar
is is any cheaper if you then add on the
cost of the high-voltage cables which I
understand of course are technically
feasible we're talking about a very
complex very expensive system it is a
highly ambitious project and I can't see
that it's going to make a lot of
difference within perhaps the next two
decades or so and in the meantime
there'll be other technologies coming
along which would compete with it could
we just have a microphone over to the
lady over there just a few worlds back
there we go hi I'm Anna Anna Hill
founder of a sign up systems my
questions in relation to economical
economic and political cooperation and
are the mechanisms that we have for the
global energy shortages sufficient and
what would your recommendations be okay
so the first question was on the pies
for renewable energies actually it's
cheaper to build a power plant in Africa
and build a table in addition than to
try to do renewable energy in our
countries yeah so it pays off even if
you go from the south of Spain to the
north of Africa you pay off the cable
the cable from Africa to Europe is about
one cent per kilowatt-hour so it's not
really significant and the other
question was on the economy dig the
political economic cooperation is that
right with this is
yes I think the socio-economical
questions are the main problems in the
whole project technology is mostly
developed the cables are developed they
are using it in China but the
difficulties of course is to get some
political frameworks which work we also
in contact with China for example in
China is much easier they have their own
deserts they can build their power
plants and their cables and they have no
political issues there it's similar in
the US but Europe and Africa have the
additional political problems first of
all the European countries are it's a
long way that they find a common way in
this issue and then you have about 10 or
15 different countries in North Africa
and Arabia which also politically very
difficult different so it that is the
main issue and that is what what the
desert egg foundation class to push like
we are building a desert at university
network now in North Africa and we have
members from all african states in this
network but one also has to say you can
start already be later on like this
british company now between tunisia and
italy they just do it they they built
the power plants they built the cables
and then it works between britain and
algeria it would be more difficult
because there are more countries in
between and you have to somehow find
ways on how much money does switzerland
get if they put a cable for that country
and those it shows here so it's
politically it's a very difficult thing
economic economically as well but to me
it's it's worth doing it because it's it
will be and I don't agree that it see it
in expensive way in the long term I
believe it's the most cheapest way
except for offshore wind energy to do
renewable energies and it's somehow
complementary to wind energy because the
concentrated power stations can put your
power on demand
and then they can reduce the
fluctuations we will take a vote later
right at the end of the evening on these
five initiatives so and let prepare
yourselves mentally / which one you're
gonna vote for thank you very much